how has it been watching all these
reactions to The Little Mermaid and
people just like losing their mind
[Music]
I've been so emotional when I see all
the babies so I'm just really honored
and just pinching myself and I there's
the one especially of the little girl
who's like the little black girl she's
sitting down she's like she's black and
she looks at her mom
it's like me it gets you every time yeah
yeah you cry you did it yeah yeah how
excited are you for the release of this
and what will we finally get to see I'm
so excited for the release I feel like
I've been waiting for so long for people
to we've been talking about it for a
long time but now that the rollout's
starting and stuff I'm like really
grateful that everyone's gonna get to
see so yeah I hope everyone likes it
we'll see you hope come on now all right
this is like family to you this is a
family night more importantly what does
it mean what Miss Tina and Mr Lawson are
doing with Waco it means absolutely
everything you know know we do what we
do so we can give back and Inspire kids
who are our age looking up like I just
want to be my complete self and be able
to share my art and be real and I'm so
proud of Miss Tina and Mr Richard and
everything that they're doing and we all
get to dress up and feel pretty for a
good cause tonight yeah yeah and what
does Miss Tina mean to y'all
the world to us
icon she's a legend
she burped two legends like come on yeah
she has done it all one other thing what
is it like watching each other stuff is
it almost more satisfying watching each
other do well right absolutely like me I
feel like I get more excited for Chloe's
like music videos and things like that
and she does you know because she's
filled with nervousness and like oh I
don't know but I'm like girl you should
see so it's exciting it's really cool I
think I think it goes both ways because
like when you're in it you're just
focused on like your nerves and
internalizing everything but being able
to watch this and all her glory has been
so incredible and I'm so happy the world
is seeing what I've always seen since we
were like this tall so I'm so so proud
of her and everything that we're doing
together and individually we have new
music a new single dropping what can you
tell me about it yes on October 28th for
the night I'm so excited about this one
it's very near and dear to my heart and
I can finally put it out into the world
so I'm very excited what does that mean
and what can we expect to see because
you you usually bring something with it
well you can expect
definitely more of me it's very
it's very and effortless
effortlessly